hi herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video jetzt wahrscheinlich
genau wie ich in den letzten wochen die
trends angeschaut und euch ist
vielleicht auch aufgefallen dass im
moment ungefähr alles auf youtube sich
um essen drehen ich glaube der gottvater
von diesem hype ist chris page and drop
grüße gehen an dieser stelle raus und
ich dachte mir ich habe eine idee und
zwar folgende ich werde mir jetzt
wahrscheinlich schon im titel gelesen
eine pizza erstellt aber nicht irgendwie
nicht eine pizza mit käse rand oder
kanal und pizza hawaii oder so nein ich
bestellen jetzt gleich eine pizza mit
allen extra zutaten die man sich
bestellen kann ich habe eine seite
gefunden wo man hier in köln zu
verstärken und die haben unmengen an
extras aber keine formation das so und
ich würde sagen gucken wir direkt mal
rein und okay leute wir sind jetzt eben
menüs und klicken einfach mal auf pizza
weil wir wollen ja eine pizza bestellt
so dann nehmen wir doch einfach mal als
grundlage weil ich würde sagen das macht
am meisten sinn weil arbeit in ganz
anderen sachen ist ja schon zeigt ohne
ende drauf als grundlage nehmen wir mal
auf jeden fall eine margherita aber was
für eine größere nehmen wir 26 30 oder
36 26 wahrscheinlich ein bisschen klein
man muss darauf achten die extra zutaten
werden auch teurer
logischerweise wenn die pizza größer ist
deshalb nehmen wir einfach mal die
goldene mitte und nehmen eine mittlere
margarita die kostet sechs euro 90 also
der grundpreis sind sechs euro 90 zeigen
sagt ich hab noch nicht gefrühstückt
heute das heißt ich hoffe wirklich es
schmeckt einigermaßen in ordnung
ich gehe damit gleichen die uni und
davor muss ich diese pizza verdrücken
klicken wir jetzt einfach mal auf extras
wir haben jetzt hier einerseits die
basic zutaten basic zwei zutaten deluxe
zutaten und gratis zutaten schauen wir
mal die besten zutaten haben wir haben
anlass ich würde sagen anlass nehmen wir
einfach mal ab die schotten an die
schotten und anna loos passen perfekt
zusammen nehmen wir einfach mal
blattspinat klar unbedingt frische
tomaten okay da kann man nichts falsch
machen weiter frisches basilikum kann
man auch nichts falsch machen
capesius karten ich mag eigentlich keine
karten aber ich nehme alles also das
letzte mal keine cup und ich hasse es
jetzt nicht oder so aber
leute ihr seht es hier oben grundpreis
sechs euro 90 extras 50 euro 90 das ist
ohne witz wahrscheinlich die teuerste
patch hatte ich jemals essen werde und
ich bin auch wirklich gespannt wie sie
darauf reagieren weil garantiert kommen
irgendwie anrufen wenn er meinen sie das
ernst aber ich bezahle schon direkt mit
paypal damit die wissen erst das geld
bei ihnen ist und dann kommen ja nicht
auf die liste oder so das übernehmen wir
jetzt mal alter wie das aussieht diese
liste hier also alle zutaten die sie
überhaupt haben bei klinger für jetzt
bestellen das würde ich jetzt mal kurz
aus wir sehen uns dann gleich wieder
bemerkungen und sonderwünsche ich
schreib einfach mal rein keine spaß
bestell und sondern ein experiment okay
dann würde ich sagen bestellung absenden
okay leute ihr seht ist hier bestellung
erfolgreich ich habe mir soeben eine
pizza für 57 euro 80 bestellt was mache
ich mit meinem leben aber ich bin
wirklich sehr gespannt wie das gleich
schmecken wird wie das vor allem
aussehen wird und ja sebastian ist auch
noch hier und ein kumpel kompletten
darum das heißt wir kriegen die schon
aufgegessen ich bin einfach gespannt
also kommt man ja schon tag hier max ich
melde mich nur weil gerade eine
bestellung bei ihnen aufgegeben habe und
sichergehen wollte dass die auch durch
geht weiß nicht ob sie es mitbekommen
und ich hatte mir eine pizza margherita
mich genau mit allen extras kommen
wahrscheinlich jeden tag vor oder aber
genau das macht es mir schon deshalb
habe ich bezahlt haben uns auch durch
geht super können wie das dazu kommt da
ist alles sagt ja das ist nicht gesagt
hat so ein kleines experiment ich mach
youtube-videos und machte mir das sei
doch ein interessantes video wenn ich
einfach mal alle zutaten auf eine pizza
packe das kommt dann auf meinen
youtube-kanal denn sollte man auch
abonnieren also
super dann weiß ich ja bescheid wann
kann ich mit der lieferung rechnen
leute ich habe gerade meine super gute
idee mit einem zu bestellen meinem
manager geschickt er meinte einfach da
machst du also das was auch schon prangt
groß und jonas gemacht haben also jufa
und ich hatte wirklich keine ahnung dass
andere leute das auch schon gemacht
haben deshalb ist das jetzt keine
geklaut idee oder so wenn ihr euch das
video in der anderen wir sehen noch mal
anschauen wollt schaut gerne bei ihnen
vorbei nur dass ich das mal gesagt habe
und jetzt gehen wir aber auch zu dem
moment wo die pizza ankommt leute hier
vor mir liegt es gerade gesehen denn
nicht bereut hat sie uns gebracht die
wussten alle bescheid ich habe ja noch
mal angerufen und alle haben schon
darüber gesprochen
dafür baut damit alle bestellt hat ich
werde gleichzeitig hart treffen und dann
gucken wir sie uns an ihr guckt sogar
vor mir leute profits er unter 3 2 1
gelang alle und und oha alter das ist
richtig geil aus ganz richtig mühe
gegeben oder an der kamera vorbei was
ist das eher hähnchen kanälen oliven
steak paprika brokkoli ananas brokkoli
basilikum tomaten calacanis klar was
haben wir noch alles gelaufen
darunter sind glaube ich artischocken
wahrscheinlich an natürlich hat
welchen klub linker tanken box usa
hauptwort alter noch nicht gegessen sagt
man nichts gegessen jetzt darüber mag es
ist früher abend mesz
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass sie so sehr
eine pizza einfach aus die beste war das
werd ich hätte gedacht das sei einfach
zu nutzen ist eine torte hat aber es ist
halt schon krass wenn du mal so runter
gehst du dass man die dicke sieht dies
schon gestellt
wie ist dieser nicht mal so dick macht
man warte mal bevor die anschneidet du
siehst es ist keine alte dicke pizza
vergiss nicht diese pizza 56 euro
gekostet gab es schon gras kurz darauf
ist es einfach nur wissen was drauf aber
nein also 56 euro
sinn macht das natürlich nicht das
system ist ja nicht darauf ausgelegt
dass du dir so viel darauf weil er so
viel geld damit verdient ja ich nehme so
ein halbes ei draufgemacht vor ort
deshalb leute dass keine drogen sein
teilt das video damit auch ich viel geld
damit verdienen sehr gut schneiden wir
sie an die pizza torte für 57 euro
mit allen zutaten das ist schon weg ich
bin gespannt fall ist es auch scharfe
soße juni verwaltete drauf weiß habe ich
ja auch gerade entdeckt natürlich dann
wenn er probieren was meint ihr augen zu
beim reinbeißen und sag mir was du alles
schmeckt ok ja ich probiere alles zu
schmecken
[Musik]
so gewinnt man schmeckt halt vor allem
zu tun als mit sogar so krass weg aber
ohne spaß dass ich jetzt nicht so
schlecht kann man essen kann man voll
essen also vielleicht hat ja gerade
einen guten witz und erwischt aber alt
da waren leute wieder die zutaten raus
kompletter quatsch
das voll in ordnung also ich hätte
gedacht wäre nicht so lecker niemals
niemals dies bestätigte heute die aktien
abstand von drei zentimetern zwischen
basilikum o liebe seele steak rapelius
ananas paprika das ist halt alles in
einem bisschen drin und du sagst das ist
okay das volk riet ich bin mir jetzt in
dem bistum regensburg das alles drauf
alba kann sport keinen spaß
ich empfehle es niemanden der hunger hat
oder so aber man kann es wirklich essen
und das klasse ist du hast echt bei
jedem biss was anderes so erster bist ok
schmeckt von normalen dann hat hier
ananas radios oder irgendwie so eine
scharfe wurst oder sowas ist
vollgestellt
aber es ist folgen probier mal gewann
vor der unglaublichen plätze champion
brückengeländer das bekannteste hat
denke ich darüber nach das ist komisch
so man schmeckt wie auch geschmackstest
macht man sich ja dann wissen wir
silikon sagen erst einmal die haller
paniert jetzt geben wir zu dominante
geschmäcker paprika und daniele pecci
garnelen sind schon sind schon kreiert
also das muss man sich so rainer paetsch
max dann kommt so eine garnele anders
abläuft haben gab es das nächste
maschinen dazu sagt dass da irgendwie
hast du nicht mein videos reinpacken
der redet einfach dazwischen ja hallo
und dann wenn man etwas von dem höheren
werden sagt ihr nichts
aber es ist deine meinung nicht so
schlimm wie man denkt oder guy leiter
oder ohne wird die sache ist leute kann
man die forscher weil die so sieht aber
man hat so böse tapajós und zog so
sachen die den geschmack dominieren und
dann schmeckt ist aber fast mit pizza
man weiß halt auch eine kanäle
dazwischen aber es geht freut er sich
erst jetzt auch mainz mit
da ist auch wenn ihr mal mit eurer
familie was essen wollen wir stellen
einfach so eine pizza mit allem das tut
ihr die mitte vom tisch und jeder nimmt
sowie bei so einem koreanischen barbecue
nur das was er will
heute werden die pilze jetzt fast fertig
und uns fallen immer noch neue sachen
darauf gerade zum beispiel die am kapern
entdeckt die die auch schon wieder ganz
vergessen
7 juni wird sich gerade also dass ich
auch gerade sehr gut ist leider das ding
ist halt mein magen wird wahrscheinlich
komplett verrückt spielen aber so ein
sebastian und er würde sich so was auch
selbst backen denn nimmt einfach alles
was im kühlschrank hat schmeißt auch
eine pizza ist das einfach so das keinen
spaß mehr macht das will ich ja könnte
wirklich passiert ja oder karat und
döner zum frühstück ist auch so
sebastian 23 uhr schlafen oder das also
ich will jetzt spannend ich halte euch
auf dem laufenden leute das war's dann
auch vom experiment ich bin eine saat
und die anderen beiden jungs essen
gerade noch die letzten stücke ja leute
das war's werden sie komplett
aufgegessen und ich muss wirklich sagen
es war ein interessantes experiment so
ich fühle mich jetzt nicht so als hätte
ich geld zum fenster rausgeworfen weil
so ein problem leid aber glücklich das
ist klar das war jetzt keinen war nicht
schlau oder so aber es ist halt ich bin
aber eine erfahrung reicher
und was ist das für eine story wie viele
menschen ich kennst du dich schon mal
eine pizza mit allem gestellt haben für
57 euro
nur ein nur ein kind ich okay leute wenn
euch das video vom hartplatz gehen die
schranken kommentar schickt eure
großeltern und bis zum nächsten mal